THIS IS NOW IN SESSION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. OUR QUE HAN. BENNETT
BERMAN. BIGELOW BLOOM.
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA. BRIAN
CALDERON. CARRILLO CERVANTES.
CHEN ZI.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY. DAILY DAVIES.
FLORA MIKE FONG. VINCE FONG.
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL. GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GRAY. GRAYSON HANEY.
HOLDEN IRWIN. JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KILEY. LACKEY LI LEVINE
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN WHEN A DONALD PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS WORK QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SEYARTO SMITH.
STONE KING BY A TERRACE VIA PULA
. L. WALDRON LORD WEBER WICKS
WILSON WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR
KHAN HUMANNESS- IN THE NAME OF
GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. ALL MONEY GOD. HELP US
TO STAMP OUT HATRED AND BIGOTRY
. ALLOW US TO EMBRACE LOVE AND
CONCERN FOR OTHERS. CAN YOU
EXPECT FROM US ALL. BRING PEACE
IN OUR TIME WELL LORD. AND GIVE
US THE COURAGE TO BRING POSITIVE
CHANGE I MEAN. WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
. PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WENDY AS SHE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER. IS JOIN ME IN
SALUTE TO THE GREATEST NATION IN
THE WAR I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. AS. ZERO SAN. IS. THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO WAS ABLE SIX POINT
ONE TO THIS HOMIE MINUTES SEVEN
AM UNTIL PATRICK O'DONNELL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SENATE-DISTRICT
RESIDING SHE WORKS TO PARK AT
THE DESK WAITING FOR ACTIVITY
BERMAN READING LOCAL FARMER
PLACED UPON THE MORNING RECALLED
SEVENTY MAYES REYES MOVES AND MR
GALLAGHER SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE MOVIE TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY IT WILL BE
DEEMED READ. AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. M. IS RAISE YOUR
RECOGNIZE YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS GALLAGHER AND
BLOOM TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY HELLO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOAD TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. YEAH WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO ORDER SB NINE HUNDRED
WILL DIE THOUGH TO THE SECOND
READING FILE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY ROLE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO. I AM
NOT REFERRING ITEM TEN AB THIRTY
FIVE RADIUS TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA
THE FINAL NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO
HEAR AB THIRTY FIVE REYES ON
WEDNESDAY MAY ELEVENTH AT NINE
AM IN ROOM FOUR FOUR SEVEN.
AGAIN WITHOUT A OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINE SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. TO WITHDRAW
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT CHOI
FROM THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND ORDERED THE BILL
TO SECOND READING THE BILL IS NO
LONGER FISCAL. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY WILL. TWENTY THREE NINE
TWENTY SEVENTY ONE TWENTY SIX
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
THREE TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN
FORTY THREE TWENTY SIX NINE NINE
HE DENIED THE MEN'S AND TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHT SOME OF THE MOMENTS.
ALL BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION. WE
WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM NINETY
NINE. H. R. ONE OH TWO. BY MR
LOW FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD
READING. THE CLERK WILL READ
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE INTO MY
SUMMER LOAN OTHERS RELATED TO
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH. YEAH
MISTER LOWE YOU MAY OPEN ON THE
MEASURE. FOR COLLEAGUES HAPPY
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER HERITAGE
MONTH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PROVIDING US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CELEBRATE. REFLECTS REJUVENATE.
AND TO RECALL OUR HISTORY OUR
DEEP HISTORY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CELEBRATE OFTENTIMES WITH
INCREDIBLY DELICIOUS FOOD. BUT
AT THE SAME TIME THIS ALSO. IS
AN MOMENT IN TIME. TO TALK ABOUT
. WHERE WE COME. AND WE'RE WE'VE
BEEN. SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW AND
RECALL THE FACT THAT INDIVIDUALS
LIKE MYSELF AS A FOURTH
GENERATION CALIFORNIAN. WE'RE
NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE THE RIGHTS
THEM AFFORDED TODAY. THE RIGHTS
AS ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS. WE
REMEMBER THE CHINESE EXCLUSION
ACT OF EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO. BACK
IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO WHAT YOU
SAID BUT THAT IS SO LONG AGO
THIS WOULD NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
WHEN IN FACT WE ARE SEEING. THE
UNCANNY PARALLELS. I'M EXCLUSION
. TOWARDS OUR MUSLIM BROTHERS
AND SISTERS WITH THE MUSLIM BAN
THAT JUST HAPPENED JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO. W REMEMBER THE
CALIFORNIA ALIEN LAND LAW OF
NINETEEN TWELVE WHICH FORBID.
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS FROM
OWNING PROPERTY IN CALIFORNIA.
HOW COULD THAT HAPPEN. WE
REMEMBER THAT INTERRACIAL
MARRIAGE. WAS ILLEGAL AND
UNLAWFUL. REMEMBER THE JAPANESE
INTERNMENT. IN WHICH INDIVIDUALS
LIKE THE LATE NORMAN MINETA. I
GREW UP AS A PATRIOT. WAS IN
TURN AND INSTEAD OF RUNNING AWAY
. HE ANSWERED THE CALL TO PUBLIC
SERVICE. SERVING AS MAYOR OF SAN
JOSE'S SERVING AS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS SERVING AS COMMERCE
SECRETARY SERVING AS
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY IN TWO
DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATIONS BOTH
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT THAT IS
THE ESSENCE OF THE ASIA PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME. WE ARE NOT YOUR MODEL
MINORITY. THE NOTION THAT WE
WILL KEEP TO OURSELVES WORKED
VERY HARD NOT RUFFLE FEATHERS.
THERE'S OFTENTIMES IT. HOW MUCH
AND WHICH WOULD SEE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITY GROUPS MARCHING ON THE
STREETS. WOMEN'S MARCH. I WAS
PRIDE BLACK LIVES MATTER.
PROTESTING AT THE AIRPORT IN THE
MUSLIM BAN AND I WOULD ASK. WHAT
DO ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS MARCH
FOR. WELL WE MARCH FOR THE SAME
THINGS THAT WE STAND FOR IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
INCLUSIVE STATE FOR EVERYONE FOR
ALL THAT COULD PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GOING FROM
FORBIDDING. ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS FROM OWNING PROPERTY
TO NOW SERVING IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO NOW SERVING AS- A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE. SERVING
AS A STATE TREASURER SERVING AS
- A STATE CONTROLLER SERVING AS
A SENATOR SERVING AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. AND THAT IS WHAT WE ARE
ASKING FOR NOW. WHICH IS THERE
IS THE RECENT ATTACKS TO
STOPPING ASIAN HATE. AND WE ARE
SADDENED WHY WHY WOULD MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY ATTACKS FOR
JUST BEING THEMSELVES BEING
AUTHENTICALLY THEMSELVES KEEPING
THEIR HEADS DOWN WORKING VERY
HARD. WAT WAS THE CRIME THAT
THEY COMMITTED. IN THIS COUNTRY. AND SO THIS MONTH. AND THE
COMMUNITY NOT JUST TO CELEBRATE
WHEN THE FOOD IS DELICIOUS. BUT
TO MARCH WITH US TO FIGHT WITH
US TO STAND WITH US. TO HOLD OUR
HANDS IN SOLIDARITY FOR UP
LIFTING THE COMMUNITY AND
CORPORATE BOARDS IN HOLLYWOOD
AND ENTERTAINMENT. IN EDUCATION
. IN THE HOUSE OF LABOR AND IN
THE HOLES OF THIS BUILDING THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE. COLLEAGUES YOU
ARE GOING TO SEE AN INCREDIBLE
ARRAY OF TALENTED ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO WORK IN
THIS SPACE AND I HOPE YOU'LL
TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO THANK
THEM FOR WHAT THEY DO. AND GO
BACK IN YOUR COMMUNITIES AS WELL
. N. RECOGNISING COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS DOING WORK IN THE
SPACE TO UPLIFT ASIAPLUS HONOR
COMMUNITY. LASTLY MAY JUST. SAY
TO OUR COLLEAGUES AND OUR
MEMBERS OF ASIA PER SILENT OR
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. THANK YOU
FOR WHICH YOU DO. BUT LET US
REMEMBER THAT THE FIGHT
CONTINUES. AND AS WE- REFLECT ON
THE MONTH OF MAY AS THE MONTH OF
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS. THIS
REMEMBER REMEMBER THIS CALL TO
ACTION IN THE CALL THE SERVICE.
AND WITH THAT. I ASK ALL OF YOU
FOR SUPPORT. AND RECOGNITION
SOLIDARITY ALLY SHIP AND YOUR UN
WAVERING COMMITMENT TO UPLIFTING
THE ASIAN DESIGN A COMMUNITY BY
VOTING IN SUPPORT OF HR ONE ZERO
TWO RECOGNIZING THE MONTH OF MAY
AS ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
HERITAGE MONTH. THANK YOU MR LOW
DR CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND A MEMBER
OF SITE AND THEN ALSO- MY
MEMBER- OF FROM. SAN JOSE
AUTHORING THE ASSAULT. HR ONE OH
TWO I'M PROUD TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF- AS A CO AUTHOR OF ALL HR ONE
OF TO WHICH IT IS ASKING AS OF
MAY. TWENTY TWENTY TWO S. ARE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER. HERITAGE
MONTH. MAY IS CELEBRATED. S. R.
E. A. P. I. OUR HISTORY AND
ACHIEVEMENTS- AND THE
CONTRIBUTION MONTH. CALIFORNIA
IS HOMES ARE FOR MANY MANY ARE
ASIANS. IN FACT THERE 16% OF THE
POPULATION IS- ASIAN AMERICANS.
THAT IS SO OVER US SIX POINT
THREE MILLION API COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. IN CALIFORNIA AS
LARGEST- AND THE FASTEST GROWING
API POPULATION IN THE UNITED
STATES. ASIA ASIAN AND THE
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICANS SO
CONTRIBUTE TO- IN MANY MANY
AREAS. AND THE CONTINUED TO MAKE
A CONTRIBUTION SO- TO LEAD TO
INTERFERE OF OUR OUR FASHION.
BUSINESS TECHNOLOGY SCIENCE A
GOVERNMENT THE LOW. HUMANITIES
OF MEDICINES POSADA
ENTERTAINMENT. NATIONAL MANY
PEOPLE KNOW THAT THE BTS. AFTER
THIS LAST DAY WE CELEBRATED JUNE
TWO DAYS K. POP. CHASING WE USED
TO CELEBRATE THE J. JANUARY
THIRTEENTH SAY EACH MONTH AS A
KOREAN AMERICAN DAY BUT BECAUSE
OF A PANDEMIC OF WE HAVE TO SKI
A COUPLE COUPLE YEARS SO- WE CAN
COME. TO SEE NOW FOR NEXT YEAR.
TODAY WE CELEBRATE THE-
INCREDIBLE CONTRIBUTIOS FOR
MEMBER OF UP APR. COMMUNITY AND
WE ARE. RESOLVED A TOOK ON. FIVE
FOR THE PRIORE SO INTO. THIS IS
A. ONE OF THEM MOST OF IMPORTANT
ISSUES OF IS A. ASIAN HEY CRIME
. NOT JUST OVER. BUT THE WE TO
HAVE SO HOW YOU ALL COME. AND
HELPING STOP THIS CELL REYES.
RACIAL HEY CRIME AS YOU THERE
YOU IS THE. WE'LL DOT HOW TO
LIVE TOGETHER IN HARMONY. I MADE
A ABA MULTI CULTURE BACKGROUND.
IF WE HATING. ONE AND THE BASED
UPON RACE. WHERE CAN WE FIND THE
PEACE AND THE- A- HEY MONTH OF
IS THE MY OF TO. RECOGNIZE. OUR
CONTRIBUTION AND THE WIND TO.
WORK TOGETHER TO STOP THIS AUTO
HEY. I ASK FOR- I'VE ON-
IMPORTER. H. R. ONE OR TO
RESOLUTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DR CHOI AND MISTER LEE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE L.
G. B. T. Q. PLUS CAUCUS TO HONOR
ASIAN AMERICAN NATIVE HAWAIIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER HERITAGE
MONTH AS SOMEONE WHO SHARES BOTH
IN THESE IDENTITIES ARE PROBABLY
ABLE TO CELEBRATE TODAY AS SOME
OF THE MOST DIVERSE COMMUNES IN
THE UNITED STATES CALIFORNIA'S
HOME TO THIS INCREDIBLE
CELEBRATION AT THE INTERSECTION
OF BEING A. P. I. N. L. G. B. T.
Q. WE WERE MET REMINDED BY THE
GREAT FOLKS AND ICONS OF
CALIFORNIA. LIKE CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSMAN MARK TAKANO WHO IS
THE FIRST OPENLY LGBT Q. PERSON
OF COLOR EVER ELECTED TO
CONGRESS AND OF COURSES OF API
DESCENT WE ALSO OF COURSE HAVE
ENTERTAINMENT ICONS LIKE GEORGE
TAKEI TO K. WHO SURVIVED THE
HORRORS OF JAPANESE INTERMENT
AND HAS NOW GONE ON TO SPARE SO
MANY FOLKS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND WE ALSO HAVE S. ERA. TO ABU
WHO PLAYED IN THE NFL THROUGHOUT
THE NINETIES AS A DEFENSIVE
TACKLE ONE CAME OUT IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO FONG RETIREMENT AND
BECAME ONE THE FIRST NFL PLAYERS
TO EVER COME OUT SO DURING THIS
MONTH WE MUST NOT FORGET THE
INTERSECTIONS AT THE LGBTQ PLUS
AN API CAN YOU SHARE AND THE
PROGRESS THAT'S BEEN MADE AND
THE CONTINUED FIGHT FOR QUALITY
THROUGH SOLIDARITY. THANK YOU.
THANK MISLI MS BONTA. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I PROBABLY
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF H.
R. ONE ZERO TWO SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT MAY HAS BEEN A
DEDICATED TIME TO CELEBRATE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER HERITAGE
THIS MONTH OF MAY WAS SELECTED
TO COMMEMORATE THE ARRIVAL OF
THE FIRST KNOWN JAPANESE
IMMIGRANTS TO THE U. S. ON MAY
SEVENTH EIGHTEEN FORTY THREE. IT
WAS JUST THIRTY YEARS AGO THAT
MAY WAS FIRST OFFICIALLY
DESIGNATED ASIAN AMERICAN ASIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO OUR NATION'S LARGEST
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN COMMUNITY WITH SIX
POINT THREE MILLION PEOPLE
MAKING SIGNIFICANT POLITICAL
CULTURAL SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
CONTRIBUTIONS IN THE AREAS OF
POLICY BUSINESS TECHNOLOGY
EDUCATION SCIENCE GOVERNMENT
MEDICINE SPORTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT. NOTABLE API
FIGURES THAT HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR THE
ADVANCEMENT OF CALIFORNIA
INCLUDE BUT ARE CERTAINLY NOT
LIMITED TO THE OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND CHINESE WORKERS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE BUILDING OF
THE TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD
LARRY IT LEON AND FELT VERY CUTE
VERACRUZ LATELY ON A FELT A
FILIPINO LABOR LEADER WHO
IMMIGRATED TO STOCKTON AND CO
FOUNDED THE UNITED FARM WORKERS
MOVEMENT. IT LEON MOST NOTABLY
ORGANIZED ALONGSIDE SISTER
CHAVEZ AND DELORES WORKED THAT
AS A LEAD FILIPINO AND LATINO I
GREW CULTURAL WORKERS AND THE
DELANO GRAPE STRIKE. UT WHAT YA
I JAPANESE AMERICAN NATIVE SAN
PEDRO KNOWN FOR HER POLITICAL
ACTIVISM AND WHO FOUGHT ON THE
FRONT LINES FOR THE CIVIL RIGHTS
OF ALL PEOPLE. AS FOUNDER OF
ASIAN AMERICANS FOR ACTION COURT
YAMASAKI TO BUILD A MORE
POLITICAL ASIAN AMERICAN
MOVEMENT THAT WOULD LEND ITSELF
TO THE STRUGGLE FOR BLACK
LIBERATION. KOTTAYAM I WOULD
MEET HER GOAL EVENTUALLY JOINING
FORCES WITH MATHEMATICS WORKING
FOR RACIAL RACIAL JUSTICE AND
HUMAN RIGHTS. WELL MY CHEN A
CHINESE AMERICAN WAS THE FIRST
WOMAN AND THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN TO HOLD THE POSITION OF
ASSEMBLY MAJORITY LEADER. SHE
WAS A PASSIONATE ACTIVIST FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS AND EDUCATION AND
HEALTHCARE. KAMALA HARRIS THE
DAUGHTER OF INDIAN AND JAMAICAN
IMMIGRANTS A DAUGHTER OF OAKLAND
IS THE FIRST FEMALE FIRST BLACK
AND FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN U. S.
VICE PRESIDENT. AS WE CELEBRATE
AAPI HERITAGEMONTH AND THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE API
COMMUNITY WE MUST ALSO CONTINUE
TO SPEAK OUT. ABOUT THE HARMFUL
DISCRIMINATION AND PHYSICAL
THREATS OF VIOLENCE INFLICTED ON
OUR COMMUNITIES. SINCE THE START
OF CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER WOMEN HAVE
REPORTED UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF
STREET HARASSMENT IN CALIFORNIA.
ON MARCH SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE A GUNMAN IN ATLANTA ENTERED
THREE SEPARATE SPAS KILLING
EIGHT PEOPLE INCLUDING SIX WOMEN
OF ASIAN DESCENT. THIS STATE IS
A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. AND AS A
MOTHER OF THREE BLACK LATINO.
AND FILIPINO CHILDREN. THESE
INCIDENTS HIT ESPECIALLY CLOSE
TO HOME. AS CALIFORNIANS ARE
STATES DIVERSITY AS A BEACON OF
PRIDE AND A SOURCE OF STRENGTH.
YOU MUST BE WILLING TO DO
EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR POWER TO
STAND UP TO THOSE THREATENS BY
THOSE AND PROMOTE RACIAL
HARMONY. LET US REMAIN MINDFUL
TO CELEBRATE AND UPLIFT OUR API
FRIENDS NEIGHBORS BROTHERS AND
SISTERS. IN SUPPORT OF OUR
FRIENDS COLLEAGUES BROTHERS AND
SISTERS AND NEIGHBORS IN THE API
COMMUNITY I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE FOR HR
ONE OH TWO. GIVE THANK YOU MISS
BONTA MISSED ONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY N BEHALF
OF LEGISLATIVE WOMAN'S CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE
ZERO TWO RECOGNIZING MAY AS
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
HERITAGE MONTH. I WANT TO ALSO
THANK OUR SOME WOMEN FROM SAN
JOSE FOR BRING THIS RESOLUTION
AND FOLLOW ALL HIS EFFORTS IN
THE ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
SINCE THE ELECTION OF THE FIRST
API WOMAN INTO THE STATE
ASSEMBLY IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX.
API WOMEN HAVE BEEN HELD MANY
POSITIONS REPORT IS AN
INFLUENCE. THAT WOMAN MARCH FONG
EU WOULD LATER GO ON TO BE THE
FIRST WOMAN AND FIRST API
PERSON. TO WIN A STATEWIDE
ELECTION WHICH SHE WAS ELECTED
SECRETARY STATE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. LATER ON SHE
CONTINUE HER PUBLIC SERVICE
CAREER AND SERVICE THE UNITED
STATE AMBASSADOR. TO MICRONESIA
FROM NINETEEN NINETY FOUR TO
NINETEEN NINETY SIX. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE BUILDING WAS
RENAMED IN HER HONOR. MAKING HER
THEIR FIRST. TIME A STATE OWNED
BUILDING HAS BEEN NAMED IN HONOR
OF AN API WOMAN. OVER THE YEARS
SINCE SECRETARY FONG USE
HISTORICAL ACTION AND CAREER
MANY API WOMEN HAVE SERVED BOTH
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE. AND
HAVE HELD STATEWIDE OFFICE. EACH
AND INFLOWS OF A PRY WOMAN GOES
FAR BEYOND AND JUST NOT JUST OUR
CAPITAL. IT IS ALSO THE HALLS OF
THE WASHINGTON DC TODAY WE HAVE
FOR API WOMEN FROM BOTH PARTIES.
CURRENTLY REPRESENTING- FOR
REPRESENTING CONGRESS. AS A
PROUD AMERICAN WOMAN AND THE
ONLY API WOMAN LEGISLATOR
SERVING TODAY. VERY DIFFERENT
THAN WHEN I CAME HERE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN WHERE
THERE WERE FIVE OF US. I AM
HONORED TO STAND ON THE SOCIAL
ORDERS OF THE API WOMAN WHO CAME
BEFORE ME AD I'M PROUD TO ALSO
BE ABLE MODEL FOR THE YOUNG
WOMAN ANGERS. THAT WILL COME
AFTER ME. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
STAND AS PICKUP AGAINST HATE
AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS AND JUST
AGAINST ANYBODY IN CALIFORNIA
AND NATIONALLY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MISS WHEN MR
PATTERSON. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
. I SPENT A SUPPORT OF THIS-
RESOLUTION AS THE SINGLE AND THE
ONLY MEMBER OF THE PJ PATTERSON
CAUCUS. HE IS MY OLDEST SON MANY
OF YOU KNOW THE STORY OF BJ BJ
WAS WERE OFFENDED DURING THE
VIETNAM WAR. THREE G. I.'S
ESCAPING AND TRYING TO GET TO
THE HELICOPTERS THAT THE-
EVACUATED- OUR OUR SOLDIERS
FOUND HIM ON THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD. TOOK HIM TO A CATHOLIC
ORPHANAGE WHERE HE WAS CARE FOR
PRESIDENT FORD SENT OVER THE C.
FIVE DAYS ON OPERATION OPERATION
BABY LIFT HE FLEW TO THE UNITED
STATES AND SHARON AND I ADOPTED
HIM WHEN HE WAS EIGHTEEN MONTHS
OLD. HE IS THAT THE LIGHT OF OUR
LIVES. THE FIRST THOUGHT THAT BJ
WAS VIETNAMESE AND FOR MOST OF
HIS LIFE WITH US. WITHOUT THE
HERITAGE WAS BE. SEVERAL YEARS
AGO BEST OF THE- HE WAS ONE OF
THE SURVIVORS OF THE CRASH C.
FIVE AIR AIRPLANE BY THE WAY
THEY ALL GET TOGETHER AND THEY
HAVE. PUT UP DNA BANK TOGETHER.
AND CALL ME UP AFTER HE GOT HIS
DNA SWAB HE SAID THAT ALL THESE
YEARS THOUGHT IT WAS. THE
ENEMIES. IS A ONE ONE THIRD
JAPANESE AND TWO THIRDS CAMBODIA
. THIS IS THAT IS THAT HI JOHN I
MIGHT. CHAPEL MODI'IN- CAMPANI
EASE. BUT HE SAID DAD I'M A 100%
I RECKON AND I'M A 100%
PATTERSON. SO YOU KNOW YOU IF
YOU IF YOU TAKE ON MY ASIAN SON
YOU TAKE ON HIS DAD. AND HE IS A
FRESH REMINDER. WHERE WE HAVE
COME FROM. I APPRECIATE THE
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE
REMINDING US OF BUT THE BAD NEWS
OF THE PAST OKAY SOMETHING
THERE'S GOOD NEWS IN THE PRESENT
AND WE NEED TO SUPPORT THAT AND
CELEBRATE THAT. THIS YOUNG MAN
TODAY IF HE WERE HERE HE WOULD
SAY HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR THE G.
I.'S HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR BABY
LEFT HAD IT NOT BEEN THAT YOU
TOOK US INTO YOUR HOME. I WOULD
BE BEHIND A WATER BUFFALO IN A
COMMUNIST COUNTRY IN A- IN A
RICE PADDY. TODAY AT FIFTY. HE
HAS INTER RACIALLY MARRIED BY
THE WAY. AN ACCOUNTANT HE IS NOW
A PLUMBING CONTRACTOR. EVERY
FAMILY NEEDS AN ACCOUNTANT AND A
PLUMBER. MBJ HAS PROVIDED US
WITH BOTH HE IS A JOY TO US AND
HE IS AN ABSOLUTE FRESH REMINDER
THAT THERE WERE THE BAD OLD DAYS
WHEN PEOPLE LIKE MIKE B. J.
WOULD HAVE BEEN SCORNED AND NOT
ALLOWED TO OWN PROPERTY. TODAY
HE OWNS HIS OWN HOME HE OWNS HIS
OWN BUSINESS. MARRIED AND DOING
EXTREMELY WELL. THAT HE IS AS I
SAID THE DELIGHT OF OUR HEARTS
AND A FRESH REMINDER OF THE PAST
THAT WAS BUT THE FUTURE AND THE
PRESENT THAT IS WHAT I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT NOT ON MY BEHALF
BUT ON BEHALF OF BJ PATTERSON.
M. MISTER BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR ME TO ASK. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF HR ONE OR TWO. AND I
WANT TO THANK MY AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CAMPBELL- FOR
BRING FOR THIS RESOLUTION WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE HISTORY
ACHIEVEMENTS AND CONTRIBUTIONS
OF ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICANS. CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
OVER SIX POINT THREE MILLION
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICANS
MORE THAN ANY OTHER STATE. AN
API COMMUNITY ITSELF REFLECTS
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSITY. THIS
RESOLUTION HIGHLIGHTS THE MORE
THAN THIRTY DIVERSE ANCESTRIES
THAT ENCOMPASS THE API COMMUNITY
. A. P. I. AMERICAN HERITAGE
MONTH IS A MONTH TO CELEBRATE
THE DIVERSE CULTURES OF THE API
COMMUNITY AND RECOGNIZE THEIR
DURING CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
ARTS. BUSINESS EDUCATION
ENTERTAINMENT FASHION THE
HUMANITIES LAW MEDICINE SCIENCE
SPORTS TECHNOLOGY IN THE
GOVERNMENT BOTH IN THE NATION'S
CAPITAL AND HEARING CALIFORNIA.
WELL THIS MONTH IS A TIME FOR
CELEBRATION WE CANNOT FORGET
THAT ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICANS HAVE ALSO IN TOWARD
EXCLUSION DISCRIMINATION AND
XENOPHOBIA IN SOME OF THE
DARKEST TIMES IN OUR HISTORY.
UNFORTUNATELY AS WE ALL KNOW TOO
WELL THE SCAPEGOATING OF API
COMMUNITY IS NOT LIMITED TO OUR
PAST BUT IS PERVASIVE TODAY.
THIS PAST SUMMER THE OWNER OF A
LOCAL SUSHI RESTAURANT IN MY
DISTRICT SOMEONE WHOSE FAMILY
HAS BEEN IN THE UNITED STATES
LONGER THAN MY OWN FAMILY. WAS
BERATED WITH THE RACIST AND
XENOPHOBIC TIRADE. SHE WAS TOLD
TO GO BACK TO HER COUNTRY. HER
COUNTRY'S AMERICA WE MUST
CONTINUE TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST
THE VIOLENCE AND RACISM THAT THE
API COMMUNITY IS FACED AND
CONTINUES TO FACE IN OUR OWN
DISTRICTS. THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
STANDS IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
API COMMUNITY IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST HATRED AND INTOLERANCE.
AND WE ARE PROUD TO RECOGNIZE
THIS MONTH AS ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN HERITAGE
MONTH. ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON HR ONE OR TWO.
THANK YOU MISS BERMAN. AND MR
RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I
THANK YOU- MISTER SPEAKER- AND I
AS WELL RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR ONE OH
TWO YOU KNOW THIS MONTH WE
CELEBRATE OUR API- OUR COMMUNITY
AND ALL OF THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS
TO OUR STATE- AND TO OUR COUNTRY
. THE API THE COMMUNITY HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF FIGHTING FOR
EQUITY IN JUSTICE AND IN LABOR
IN EDUCATION. IN BUSINESS AND
GOVERNMENT AND SO MUCH MORE. IN
FACT IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX. A
GROUP OF FILIPINO AND MEXICAN
FARMWORKERS A JOIN FORCES. TO
STRIKE AGAINST INDECENT IN
UNLIVABLE WAGES IN SOME WORKING
CONDITIONS BY MARCHING FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN- IN- A DELAY
NO. TO RIGHT HERE OUR STATE
CAPITOL IN SACRAMENTO. AND AS WE
CELEBRATE THIS API HERITAGE
MONTH. WE RECOGNISE STORIES LIKE
THIS AND WE CONTINUE TO
CELEBRATE STAND WITH OUR API
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND ALL OF
THOSE THAT THAT THAT THAT LIVE
HERE IN THIS STATE IN OUR GREAT
COUNTRY SO WITH THAT ON BEHALF
OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MISS REAVIS I SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE HOUSE RESOLUTION MR LOW YOU
BECAUSE IF YOU WISH. I THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR RECOGNIZING THE
DEEP HISTORY OF OUR BEAUTIFUL
CALIFORNIA. AND AS WE LEAVE
THESE CHAMBERS HERE. I KNOW THAT
WE WILL GO BACK TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND UPLIFTS MEMBERS
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMITTEE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER AYE VOTE AND JUST AS A POINT
OF REFLECTION PLEASE SEE THE
TEXTBOOK THAT IS LEFT ON YOUR
DESK WHICH IS A COMPILATION OF
ASIAN AMERICAN HISTORY. AND I
HOPE THAT YOU'LL TAKE SOME TIME
TO TAKE A LOOK AND YOU'LL
CERTAINLY FIND SOME FAMILIAR
FACES I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE
. INITIAL YOU WOULD LIKE CO. ON
THE RESIN MEMBERS THE FIRST
ROLLED BE OPEN COLOR. ON THE
HOUSE RISEN CLARK LOW THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CALL. ADDING ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON HR. ONE OH TWO. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION. IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WE HAVE GUESTS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY IN HONOR OF ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH THE MEMBERS WHO
WERE PREVIOUSLY SELECTED TO BE
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER MAY
MOVE TO THE BACK AT THIS TIME.
EVERYONE ELSE PLEASE REMAIN
SEATED FOR THE DURATION OF THE
CEREMONY. TO OUR ESTEEMED GAS AS
YOUR NAME IS RED PLEASE COME TO
THE REAR CENTER I'LL TO BE
RECOGNIZED. AND THE CLERK. WILL
READ.
MISTERI CHAU EXCELLENCE IN
ADVOCACY. MISTER MITCHELL IS THE
CO FOUNDER AND CEO HATE IS A
VIRUS MISTER WAS ALSO BEEN
RECOGNIZED AS NBC ASIAN AMERICA
A TO THE RISING STAR GEORGETOWN
ARE PRINTER OF THE YEAR AND
POWER AND A POWER WOMEN IN DC
TACK.
DR KENDRA EXCELLENCE IN ARTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT. DR TANJONG IS A
POPULAR FILM AND TELEVISION
ACTOR PRODUCER AND WRITER.
OFFSCREEN DR. HAS BEEN AN
ADVOCATE FOR CHANGE IN HIS FIGHT
AGAINST THE RISE IN ASIAN ANTI
ASIAN HATE. AND WAS INSTRUMENTAL
IN HELPING PASSED THE HISTORIC
API EQUITY BUDGET.
DR CHARLES HUANG EXCELLENCE IN
BUSINESS. PASOK A CAPITAL INC'S
FOUNDER AND CHAIRMAN DR CHARLES
WONG IS A GLOBAL BUSINESS MAN
AND PHILANTHROPIST BORN N CHINA
AND EDUCATE IN CHINA AND BRITAIN
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE DOCTOR
DOCTOR WONG FOUNDED THE CHARLES
LONG FOUNDATION WITH A MISSION
TO BOLSTER ENABLE AND INSPIRE
GLOBAL DEVELOPMENT IN EDUCATION
HEALTH AND INNOVATION.
MISS MANIFOLD YAGNA ON ALLY
MANNER MANIFOLD MANIFOLD ALLY IS
A SMALL AND ACTIVISTS
REVOLUTIONARY LEADER AND
VISIONARY WHOSE REPRESENTATION
AS A COURAGEOUS ADVOCATE AND
ELECTED OFFICIAL HAS OPENED
DOORS FOR HER PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES MIGNON ALLY IS
SERVING HER THIRD TERM ON THE
JEFFERSON ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT GOVERNING BOARD IN DALY
CITY WHERE SHE GARNERED THE
HIGHEST VOTES IN THE HISTORY OF.
THIS DISTRICT ELECTION. YEAH.
OUR DR PETER BRAND EXCELLENCE IN
HEALTH UROLOGIST AND KIDNEY
TRANSPLANT SURGEON DR PETER
BRITTEN WAS THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION'S FIRST
FILIPINO AMERICAN PRESIDENT AND
THE FIRST ANSWER TO TERMS DR
BRITAIN HAS BEEN A LEADER IN
PROTECTING AND EXPANDING
UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
FOR ALL PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA%
HE IS ALSO THE FOUNDER OF LIFE
BY INTERNATIONAL WHICH RACES
LIFESAVING. COUNTRIES EARNING
HIM RECOGNITION FROM THE AIR M.
A. FOR CITIZENSHIP AND COMMUNITY
SERVICE.
MR MORROW MAEDA EXCELLENCE IN
SCIENCE. SAMARRA MEHTA IS A
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD TECH
ENTREPRENEUR STEM PROMOTER AND
GENDER EQUALITY ACTIVISTS. LAST
MONTH HER NEWEST MEDICAL
RESEARCH PROJECT WORKING ON
PRECISION MEDICINE IN OVARIAN
CANCER USING MACHINE LEARNING
TECHNIQUES. PLACED FIRST IN ALL
OF CALIFORNIA AT THE CALIFORNIA
SCIENCE AND ENGINEERING FAIR.
MISTER BRIAN HA EXCELLENCE IN
LABOR.
BRIAN IS THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONSAT THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION A
UNION OF TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
PROFESSORS LECTURERS LIBRARIANS
COUNSELORS AND COACHES WHO
TEACHER PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS. PRIOR TO
JOINING THE CFA MR HA WAS A
SUCCESSFUL ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND UNITED WAY OF
CALIFORNIA.
SHOHEI OHTANI EXCELLENCE IN
SPORTS MR TONY COULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN SHOHEI
OHTANI SIGNED WITH THE LOS
ANGELES ANGELS BRING THE
JAPANESE SUPERSTAR TO MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL SINCE HIS DEBUT
MR TONY HAS BEEN NAMED THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AMERICAN
LEAGUE MOST VALUABLE PLAYER THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AMERICAN LEAGUE
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR IS A
LOUISVILLE SILVER SLUGGER
RECIPIENT AND AN AMERICAN LEAGUE
ALL THREE MADE HISTORY AS THE
FIRST PLAYER EVER SELECTED AS
BOTH A PITCHER AND A POSITION
PLAYER.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN ONE FINAL ROUND OF
APPLAUSE RECOGNIZING OUR
ARTERIES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
MEMBERS THIS CONCLUDES THE ASIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH CEREMONY. AND YOU
MAY BE SEATED THANK MEMBERS.
MEMBERS I HAVE YOUR ATTENTION
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL GAS WITH US IN THE
ASSEMBLY. TODAY ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL WE
WELCOME MEMBERS OF THE JEWISH
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE OF
CALIFORNIA SEATED IN THE GALLERY
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON THE FILE
. WE ARE ON ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. FILE ITEMS TWELVE
THROUGH FIFTEEN PASS RETAIN WE
ARE AT MR TANG'S AMENDMENTS THIS
IS FILE ITEM SIXTEEN A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS COOPERATE
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY EIGHTEEN
SEVENTEEN AMENDS MY SUMMER TANG
MISTER CHANG ON THE MAMMOTHS I
THINK WHAT'S BECOME PRESENT
EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PROCESSING FLOOR
AMENDMENTS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE MINUTES TO SEND THE
BILL BACK TO PRINT IN PLACE TO
BACK OFF ON. THANK YOU MISTER
KING. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MEAN
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
I. SEVENTY MEMBERS HARD OPTED TO
BILLS OUT TO PRINT. AND BACK ON
FILE FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN PASS
RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN. AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN BY DOCTOR WOULD IN THE
CLERK WILL READ. THE SALE TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
BY SUMMER WOULDN'T ACCORDING TO
MEDICAL. DOCTOR WOULD THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
WOULD UPDATE AND MODERNIZE THE
OUTDATED LEGISLATIVE INTENT
LANGUAGE IN THE FIRST CODE
SECTION IN THE MEDICARE ACT
WHICH ESTABLISHES THE PURPOSE OF
THE PROGRAM. THE SECTION OF LAW
WAS LAST AMENDED IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE AND AS YOU KNOW THE
PROGRAM HAS CHANGED
SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE THAT TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
. ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY THREE KNOWS
EIGHT. THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS
IS FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY FOUR CLERK WILL READ
. SOME OF THE TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
FOUR BY SUMMER BLANCA RUBIO AND
ACCORDING TO MANY REPORTERS
MISERIA THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS UNDER CURRENT LAW
MANDATED REPORTERS ARE REQUIRED
TO REPORT KNOWN OR SUSPECTED
CHILD ABUSE. AND NEGLECT SO THAT
AN INVESTIGATION CAN TAKE PLACE
HOWEVER IF A MANDATED REPORTER
FAILED TO PROTECT A CHILD BY
FAILING TO REPORT AND ONE YEAR
PASSES THE LAW IS NO LONGER
ENFORCEABLE. THE PROBLEM WITH
THIS APPROACH IS THAT SEVERAL
CASES HAVE OCCURRED WHERE A
CHILD HAS BEEN THE VICTIM OF
PHYSICAL ABUSE OR NEGLECT. AND A
MANDATED REPORTER WAS MADE AWARE
OF THIS BUT A VARIETY FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS DID NOT
REPORT THE ABUSE TO AUTHORITIES.
THAT THIS LAPSE IN TIME
SOMETIMES MONTHS OR YEARS
CREATES A VERY DIFFICULT
PROSECUTION. OF THE PERPETRATOR
DUE TO LOST EVIDENCE AND EXPOSES
THE VULNERABLE CHILD A DANGEROUS
SITUATION OF BECOMING AN ONGOING
VICTIM A PREVENTABLE PHYSICAL
ABUSE OR NEGLECT. AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY FOUR SEEKS TO REMEDY
THIS BY MERELY EXTENDING THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS ENSURING.
MANDATED REPORTERS TAKE THIS
LEGAL RESPONSIBILITIES
SERIOUSLY. THIS MEASURE THIS
MEASURE HAS UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
IN ARM. INCOMING REMOVED
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU THIS RUBIO. SEEING
NO MEMBERS SEEKINGRECOGNITION
ON THIS ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL.
SACRAMENTO ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS AND RETAIN A FILE
ITEMS TWENTY. THROUGH TWENTY
EIGHT WE ARE GOING TO PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE. PASS A
RETAINER FILE ITEMS THIRTY.
THROUGH THIRTY SEVEN. THAT
BRINGS US TO. THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT. FOLLOW
THIRTY EIGHT AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY FOUR BY MR MCCARTY. AND A
CORPORATE ASSEMBLE TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR BY CENTER MCCARTY AND
ACCORDING TO REAL ESTATE. MR
MCCARTY YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BILL FOCUSING
ON REAL ESTATE TRANSACTIONS
INCREASINGLY INDIVIDUALS HAVE
BEEN SELLING THEIR PROPERTIES
OVER THE INTERNET THROUGH THE
AYE BUYER PROGRAMS. THIS MAKE
SURE THAT THESE REAL ESTATE
TRANSACTIONS HAVE LOCAL CONTACTS
A LOCAL REAL CONTACT HELPING THE
SELLER TO MAKE SURE WE PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS IF ANYTHING GOES
WRONG AS WELL AS ENHANCE OUR
LOCAL REAL ESTATE PROFESSION.
ASK THEIR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY. C.
NOTIFICATION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. AS
ADAM. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY SIX KNOWS NINE
THE MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEMS THIRTY NINE AND FORTY
. THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY ONE.
AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT BY MISTER
KALRA COOKERY. A SINGLE TWENTY
WAY BY SOME MEMBER KALRA
ANOTHER'S AND ACTING TO
FLUORESCENT LAMPS. YOUR KALRA
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT WOULD
PHASE OUT THE SALE AND
DISTRIBUTION AS A NEW
MANUFACTURER PRODUCT OF COMPACT
FLUORESCENT LAMPS AND LINEAR
FLUORESCENT LAMPS STARTING ON
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AND JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE RESPECTIVELY HOWEVER THIS
BILL WOULD. SPECIALTY FOR FANS
THAT CANNOT BE EASY PLACED. THIS
EXEMPTION INCLUDES BALL USING
DISINFECTION PHARMACEUTICAL
DEVELOPMENT AND MEDICAL
PRACTICE. WAFFLE RESIDENTS WERE
ONCE THE BEST ALTERNATIVE TO
INCANDESCENT LAMPS THERE ARE TWO
KEY REASONS WHY THIS IS NO
LONGER THE CASE FIRST ALL
FLUORESCENT LAMPS CONTAIN
MERCURY. A POTENT TOXIN THAT CAN
CAUSE PERMANENT DAMAGE THE
CENTRAL NERVOUS SYSTEM WHEN
FORCES BREAK THEY RELEASED THEIR
MERCURY CONTAMINATED ANYONE
ANYTHING IN THE VICINITY. SECOND
FLOREZ'S ARE NO LONGER THE MOST
ENERGY EFFICIENT BULBS WITH
MERCURY FREE LED IS ONLY
REQUIRING ABOUT HALF THE
ELECTRICITY. WHILE LASTING TWO
TO THREE TIMES LONGER. FURTHER
MORE THE COST OF LEDS IS
EXPECTED TO BE COMPARABLE TO THE
COST OF RESIDENTS BY THE TIME
THIS BILL TAKES EFFECT. BY
USHERING UP RUSSELL LAMPS AB
TWENTY TWO AWAY WILL ALLOW
BETTER ALTERNATIVES LIKE THE WAY
TO A SAFER MORE ENERGY EFFICIENT
FUTURE. WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA C. NOTIFICATION MADE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE TELEVOTE
EYES FORTY SEVEN KNOWS TWELVE.
THE MEASURE PASSES. A PASS
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS FORTY TWO
THROUGH FORTY SEVEN FILE ITEM
FORTY EIGHT IS AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY THREE BY THIS RUBIO
CORKERY ASSEMBLYBILL TWENTY ONE
SIXTY THREE BY SUMMER BLANCA
RUBIO ACCIDENTAL WATER. MS RUBIO
HE MAILED IT THANK YOU MISTER.
SPEAKER AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
THREE EXPENSES SUNSET DATE FOR
THE THANK YOU PREVENT THAT THANK
YOU BUT BASS AND WATER QUALITY
OF THIRTY TO THE YOUR TWENTY
FIFTY THE WORK DONE BY THE WATER
AT THE WATER QUALITY IT TOOK A
THIRTY IS NOT INVALUABLE TO MY
DISTRICT AND I HAVE SET THE
STANDARD. FOR EFFORTS IN
GROUNDWATER REMEDIATION THIS
MEASURE HAS UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU THIS
REVIEW C. NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBER
CENTER SERVICE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRABLE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASSWORD HAVE FILE ITEMS FORTY
NINE AND FIFTY. RAISES FILE ITEM
FIFTY ONE. AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
SIX BY MR O'DONNELL CORKERY
ASSIGNABLE TWENTY FIVE OF THE
SIX BY CINEMACON ACCORDING TO
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT MISTER
DONNELLY EMAIL BUT THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE RISEN
AB TWO FIVE FIVE SIX TO ENSURE
GOOD EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER RELATIONS
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
BOARD'S PROCESS FOR RESOLVING AN
IMPASSE ENCOURAGES BOTH PARTIES
RESOLVE THEIR DISPUTE THROUGH
MEDIATION AND FACT FINDING.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE MEDIATION
AND FACT FINDING PARTIES ARE
GIVEN ONLY TEN DAYS TO REACT TO
THOSE FINDINGS TO RESOLVE THE
REMAINING ISSUES OF CONTROVERSY
BEFORE THE PUBLIC AGENCY CAN
IMPOSE OUR LAST BEST AND FINAL
OFFER AB TWO FIVE FIVE SIX SIX
TO IMPROVE. IT ENDED IT SEEKS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FIVE DAYS FOR
PARTIES TO MEET TO DISCUSS THE
FACT FINDER'S REPORT AND WORK
TOWARDS AN AGREEMENT I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
SAYING NO DISCLOSURE BATES.
CARCLUB THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
UNDESIRABLE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE VOTE I FIFTY THREE
DOES ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FIVE SIX TWO AND FIFTY THREE
PASS RETAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY FOUR ACR ONE FIFTY THREE
BY MISTER SALAS CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCUR RESOLUTION
NUMBER FIFTY ONE FIFTY THREE BY
A SUMMER SALAS RELATIVELY STAR
MOTHERS OF AMERICA MONTH.
MISTRESS ALICE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE PROUD TO
PRESENT ACR ONE FIFTY THREE
WHICH RECOGNIZES THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF BLUE STAR
MOTHERS AND PROCLAIMS MAY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS BLUE STAR MOTHERS
OF AMERICA MONTH IN CALIFORNIA.
THE REFERENCE TO THE BLUESTAR
DATES BACK TO WORLD WAR ONE WHEN
MILITARY FAMILIES WOULD HANG A
SERVICE FLAG IN THEIR WINDOWS. A
BLUE STAR DISPLAYED FOR EVERY
LIVING FAMILY MEMBER IN SERVICE
BLUESTAR MOTHERS OF AMERICA'S
ARE THE LARGEST AND FASTEST
GROWING MILITARY FAMILY
ORGANIZATION IN THE COUNTRY. AND
IS INSPIRED MORE THAN TWENTY SIX
MILLION HOURS OF VOLUNTEER
SERVICE NATIONWIDE. LOOSER
MOTHERS OF AMERICA ARE THE
LARGEST. EXCUSE ME WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN FOR THOSE
FAMILIES AND HONOR THEIR LOVED
ONES FOR SERVING OUR COUNTRY.
OUR SERVICE MEMBERS VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES INSPIRE US EVERY
DAY AND EVERY MOMENT THROUGH
THEIR POISON RESILIENCE AND
DESERVE ALL OF OUR RECOGNITION
AND SUPPORT. THEIR MOTHERS
STEPMOTHERS FOSTER MOTHERS AND
GRANDMOTHERS YOU SHOW AND DURING
COMMITMENT AND COURAGE AND
EXEMPLIFY. THE BEST OF AMERICAN
VALUES AND PATRIOTISM. BLUESTAR
MOTHERS CAN BE FOUND TAKING CARE
OF OUR VETERANS CEMETERIES.
FUNDRAISING TO SEND CARE
PACKAGES FOR TROOPS OVERSEAS ARE
DONATING MONEY TO HELP VETERANS
ADOPT COMPANION DOGS. I HAVE
BEEN HONORED TO WORK WITH BLUE
STAR MOTHERS CHAPTERS I TO HONOR
AND RECOGNIZE ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE MEMBERS FROM THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND THE ENTIRE
CENTRAL VALLEY. COMING OFF THE
HEELS OF MOTHER'S DAY I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO REACH
OUT TO YOU BLUE STAR MOTHERS TO
RECOGNIZE AND HONOR. THEIR
COURAGE AND DEDICATION TO
PROTECTING THIS COUNTRY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON ACR ONE FIFTY THREE AND
ALSO THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CALL AUTHORS. THANK YOU MISTER
SALAS MISTER RAMOS WHO ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION AS CHAIR OF THE
MILITARY AND VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE. THAT DESIGNATES MAY
AS BLUE STAR MOTHERS OF AMERICA
MONTH IN CALIFORNIA. BLUE STAR
MOTHERS CONTINUE TO REPRESENT
THE WHOLE THERE REGARDLESS OF
ONE'S POLITICAL OR OTHER LABEL
AMERICANS CAN COME TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT ONE ANOTHER. CREATED
MORE THAN SIXTY YEARS AGO BLUE
STAR MOTHERS CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
. SERVICES TO ASSIST VETERANS
ORGANIZATIONS AND OUR SERVICE
PERSONNEL. OUR MILITARY SUPPORT
PERSONNEL PROTECT OUR COUNTRY IT
IS CRITICAL THAT WE JOINED THE
BLUE STAR MOTHERS AND
RECOGNIZING OUR MILITARY IN IN
THEIR SERVICE. THIS MOVES
FORWARD FOR US TO STAND TOGETHER
AND UNITED AND TO STAND WITH OUR
BLUE STAR MOTHERS DURING THIS
MONTH AND EVERY MONTH OF THE
YEAR I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS ROMMEL'S. SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION
MISTER SALAZAR MY CLOTHES IF YOU
WISH. JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIVEAU MISTER SPEAKER- ARE BLUE
STAR MOTHERS DO A LOT FOR THIS
COUNTRY FOR SERVICEMEN. AND I
WOULD LOVE TO REQUEST OF THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CALL
AUTHORS. DAMOS SCHAUS THE AUTHOR
TESTING OF THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON. ACR. ONE FIFTY THREE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL THEIR
SIXTY THREE CO AUTHORS ADDED AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE IT
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. AND
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN CONJUNCTION WITH A C. R. ONE
FIFTY THREE BY MISTER SALAS
SEATED IN THE GALLERY OUR
CENTRAL VALLEY BLUE STAR MOMS.
LET'S WELCOME THEM TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION TAKING A FILE I'M
TWENTY NINE. THIS IS MISTER
LEE'S. AB TWENTY TWO OH SIX THIS
IS FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE AB
TWENTY TWO OH SIX. AND THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME REAL TWENTY TWO
OH SIX BY SUMMER LEE AND
ACCORDING TO AIR POLLUTION.
MISTER LEAH MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL
EIGHT IN THE ENFORCEMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S PARKING CASH OUT
PROGRAM WHICH HAS BEEN LAW FOR
THE PAST THREE DECADES PARKING
CASH OUT PROGRAMMER PCO FOR
SHORT OR QUITE CERTAIN EMPLOYERS
OFFERING EQUAL BENEFITS
EMPLOYEES WHO DO NOT DRIVE TO
WORK. AND THEREFORE DO NOT GET
THE BENEFITS OF FREE PARKING
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS THIS PROGRAM
IS MORE EQUITY FOR THOSE WHO
RIDE A BIKE OR TAKE PUBLIC
TRANSIT TO WORK ONE THE REASONS
PCO IS NOT BEING IMPLEMENTED
PROPERLY IS DUE TO THE
DIFFICULTY IN CALCULATING THE
VALUE OF EMPLOYEE PARKING. MANY
OWNERS OF COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE
BUNDLE THE COST OF PARKING THE
COSTS IN OFFICE SPACE DO SINGLE
THESE PRICE THIS PRACTICE MAKES
IT DIFFICULT FOR EMPLOYEES
UNDERSTAND THE VALUE OF PARKING
THE PROVIDE. NEW ADDRESS IS
CONCERNED AB TWENTY TWO OH SIX
SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT THE PRICE
OF PARKING IS LISTED IN
COMMERCIAL LEASES IF THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE PCO BENEFITS
SICKLY ASK FOR EITHER. THANK YOU
ASHLEE. SAYING NO TO. OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. PARK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRABLE. WELL. CLOSE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY FOUR
KNOWS FIFTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES BACK IN FILE ORDER FILE
ITEMS FIFTY FIVE. THROUGH. SIXTY
FOUR PASS AND RETAIN. RACIST
FIVE SIXTY FIVE AC ARE ONE
FIFTEEN THE CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NUMBER ONE
FIFTEEN BY SUMMER WHEN RELATIVE
TO OLDER AMERICANS MONTH MISSED
WHEN YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT ACR ONE ONE FIVE WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE MONTH OF MAY AS
OLDER AMERICANS MONTH AND
CELEBRATES THE LIVES AND
CONTINUE CONTRIBUTIONS OLDER
AMERICANS. THEIR TIME EXPERIENCE
AND TALENT THE RICH OUR LIVES
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO NEARLY
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE AND AROUND
SIX MILLION OR CONSIDER OLDER
ADULTS RECENT ESTIMATES SHOW
THAT BUSINESS THAT NUMBER WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW AT A RATE THAT
WILL OUTPACE THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY. BY SOCIETY'S ATTITUDES
AND PERCEPTIONS OF ORDER
AMERICAN HAS CHANGED THERE IS
STILL MUCH TO BE DONE TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF THIS POPULATION AND
THE ISSUES FACING THEM. AS WE
AGE THE RESERVE ABUSE AND
NEGLECT INCREASES WE MUST BE
SURE RESOURCES ARE IN PLACE TO
PROTECT OUR OLDER POPULATION BUT
FROM THE RISK OF ABUSE AND
NEGLECT. TO DATE OLDER ADULTS
FEEL MANY NECESSARY AND
IMPORTANT ROLES AND CONTINUE TO
BE ONE OF THE GREATEST ASSET TO
OUR COUNTRY AND STATE. IN THEIR
LIFETIME BUT WHAT WHILE RAISING
FAMILIES AND BUILDING CAREERS
OLDER AMERICANS ALSO GAVE BACK
TO THE COMMUTERS IN MANY WAYS IN
THEIR LIFETIME THEY HAVE
CONTINUED TO VOLUNTEER AND SERVE
THEIR NEIGHBORS THEY MET THEY
MENTOR CHILDREN THE SERVANTS
SOUP KITCHENS. VOLUNTEER ALL
ACROSS THE COMMUNITIES AND ALSO
SERVED OUR GREAT NATION. ACR ONE
ONE FIVE CAN BE COURAGE IS ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO RECOGNIZE AND
TREAT ALL ADULT ALL OLDER ADULTS
AND SENIOR CITIZENS WITH
COMPASSION RESPECT AND ENCOURAGE
THEM TO PARTICIPATE IN
ACTIVITIES. THAT CAN THAT CAN TO
CONTINUE TO CONTINUE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR HEALTH AND
WELFARE AND HAPPINESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU MISS WHEN DR CORK
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBER FROM HUNTINGTON
BEACH VERY MUCH FOR RECOGNIZING
THE CONTRIBUTIONS. AND THE
CONCERNS OF OLDER CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION MISSED WHEN
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH. I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
VOTE I WOULD LIKE TO OPEN IT UP
FOR ANY CO AUTHORS. AUTHORS AS
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
. COME OTHERS ON THE RESOLUTION
CO AUTHORS ON A SEA OF. ONE
FIFTEEN.
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLE THERE
ARE SIXTY SIX CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX THROUGH
SIXTY EIGHT. PASS RETAIN THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTY NINE BY MISTER
NAZARIAN CORPORATE. ASSIGNABLE
TWENTY SIX SIXTY NINE BY
SEMINARIAN ACCORDING TO YOUTH
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS. MACINNES
AREA THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY NINE RESTORES
THE ONE TWO ONE MENTORSHIP MODEL
FOR ALL YOUTH SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL EXEMPTS ANY ONE TO ONE
MENTORING ORGANIZATION FROM
REQUIRING THE PRESENCE OF TWO
MANDATED REPORTERS PROVIDED THEY
HAVE POLICIES THAT ENSURE
SCREENING AND TRAINING OF THEIR
VOLUNTEERS TO TRAINING OF
PARENTS OR GUARDIANS THREE AND
HAVE REGULAR CONTACT WITH
VOLUNTEERS AND PARENTS. OR
GUARDIANS- COLLEAGUES IT'S NO
SURPRISE THAT MENTORS PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN OUR YOUTHS LIVES AND
ALLOW MANY TO HAVE THE FOSTERING
OF THE RELATIONSHIP THE LEAD
MANY SLIDES INTO WONDERFUL OF
CAREERS IN THE FUTURE WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU MRS
ARE SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THEM. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. CLARK WELL.
THOSE TIE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM SEVENTY. THROUGH. EIGHTY
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN. BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX AB TWO
THOUSAND FOUR BY MS CRISTINA
GARCIA AND THE CLERK WILL READ A
SINGLE TWO THOUSAND FOUR BY
SUMMER CRISTINA GARCIA AND
OTHERS NOT GOING TO PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION MISTER SEA
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. DURING MY TENURE
HERE WE ESTABLISHED THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM LOAN PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDES FINANCIAL AID
OPTIONS TO OUR DOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WE ESTIMATE THAT
THERE'S ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS A YEAR THAT
ARE UNDOCUMENTED AND THEIR
RESOURCES ARE LIMITED IN ORDER
TO PURSUE THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION
AND SO ON THAT PROGRAM HAS BEEN
GREAT WE HAVE LEARNED OVER THE
YEARS AND WE MUST CONTINUE TO
WORK TO IMPROVE THAT PROGRAM OUT
THERE. AND I WANT TO SHARE THE
STORY OF THE PIANO WHICH IS WHY
A CO AUTHOR OF THE ORIGINAL BILL
AND I'M DOING THIS BILL TODAY-
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL ANNA
AND I WERE IN CALCULUS TOGETHER
AND SHE WAS WORTH MORE THAN I
WAS AND WE TUTOR ME ON A REGULAR
BASIS AND WHEN I WAS TRYING TO
GRADUATING WITH A COLLEGE SHE
TOLD ME SHE WAS NOT GOING TO GO
TO COLLEGE BECAUSE SHE COULDN'T
AFFORD THE TUITION. EVEN THOUGH
SHE HAD BEEN ACCEPTED TO SOME OF
THE BEST A RELEASE OUT THERE
BACK THEN WE CAN HAVE A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS AND SO THE TWENTY
DREAM ACT A DREAM LOAN PROGRAM
INSURANCE HAVE ANYMORE STORIES
LIKE ILEANA THERE BUT IT NEEDS
IMPROVEMENTS AND SO THIS BILL.
UP INSURANCE THE PROGRAMIS
FINANCIALLY STRONG AND PROVIDE
THE SAME FINANCIAL EDUCATION IN
MARIN RELIEF AS OTHER STUDENTS
LOANS AB TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR
WILL ENSURE UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH
WHO OBTAIN A CALIFORNIA DREAM
LOAN WILL BE PROVIDED CRITICAL
RESOURCE ABOUT THE AMEN
REPAYMENT AND LEAVE OPTIONS THAT
FEDERAL LOAN PROGRAMS PROVIDE.
ADDITIONAL MORE IMPORTANTLY THIS
WILL PROBABLY PROVIDE GIVE THIS-
PROGRAM SIMILAR TO WHAT WE HAVE
IN THE FEDERAL LEVEL TWO STARTS
THESE LOANS AFTER STUDENT HAS
PROVIDED SERVICE TO THEIR
COMMUNITY AS WELL AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER. SEEN
DISCUSS OR DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLERK WILL- OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRABLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLE CALVET
EYES FIFTY THREE KNOWS THREE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE MOVE BACK IN THE
FILE TO FILE ITEM. SEVENTY ONE.
TO TAKE UP AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY IN THE CORPORATE
. ASSIGNABLE SEVENTEEN SIXTY BY
SUMMER RODRIGUEZ AND OTHERS AND
ACCORDING TO SECOND HAND GOODS
MISTER ROGERS YES THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS A. B.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY WHAT LEVY EIGHT
THE NEED FOR PALETTE TRANSFERS
TO OBTAIN OWNERSHIP OF PALLETS
IN ORDER TO MOVE AND STORE THEM
ON BEHALF OF THE BUSINESS.
ADDITIONALLY A B. SEVENTEEN
SIXTY WOULD STIPULATE THAT LET
PARENTS MUST BE COLLECTED BY THE
INDCATOR OWN WITHIN THIRTY FIVE
DAYS OF BEING NOTIFIED BY PUBLIC
TRANSFERS. PALLETS CAN
ACCUMULATE QUICKLY AND CREATE A
FIRE HAZARD AND STORAGE
CHALLENGES FOR BUSINESSES
THEREFORE IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT
PIOT TRANSFERS BE ABLE TO
COLLECT PILOTS AND STORE THEM ON
BEHALF OF THE BUSINESSES INTO
THAT BECAUSE- BY THE OWNER. A.
B. SEVENTEEN SIXTY MAKE CHANGE
THAT WILL ALLOW THE PUBLIC
MARKET PLACE THE FUNCTION
SMOOTHLY FOR ALL PARTIES AND
ENSURE THAT PUBLIC TRANSFERS ARE
NOT PENALIZED. RESTAURANTS FROM
ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUST
MISS RODRIGUEZ SEEING NO.
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM. CLERK
LIBERAL. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WELL
CLOSER ALL TIRED BUT I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS EIGHTY SEVEN AND EIGHTY
EIGHT. IN FILE ORDER PASS AND
RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY
NINE AB TWENTY NINETY FOUR BY
MISTER RIVAS AND THE CORPORATE.
SILES ONE NINETY FOUR BY SUMMER
ROBERT RIVAS AND OTHERS AND
ACCORDING TO LANNY'S MYSTERY
THIS. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
OF THIS LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY
BILL A TWO ZERO NINE FOUR SIX TO
REQUIRE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
REPORT THEIR PROGRESS. TOWARDS
THE CONSTRUCTION EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME HOUSING UNITS TO STATE
OFFICIALS AS PART OF THEIR
ANNUAL REPORTING REQUIREMENTS-
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIVEAU.
THANK YOU MISS REAVIS. THANK YOU
FOR SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM FOUR O'CLOCK
IN THE ROLE. SEVERAL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE REMOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. WELL. THOSE ARE
ALL TIED OUT I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS NINETY. AND NINETY ONE.
PASS AND RETAIN THAT BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM NINETY TWO MISTER
MCCARTY'S AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
ONE AND THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSIGNABLE TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE
BY SUMMER MCCARTY AND ACCORDING
TO FIREARMS MR MCCARTY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN OUR EFFORT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS
THE EPIDEMIC OF GUN VIOLENCE TOO
MANY OF OUR PROPOSERS ARE.
FRANKLY TOO POLARIZING AND
ELUSIVE TO GET SUPPORT FROM BOTH
SIDES THIS IS WHEN I THINK THAT
WE CAN EMBRACE IT'S ABOUT EARLY
RED FLAG WARNINGS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO SHOULD NOT BE
OWNING A FIREARM. NOR TRYING TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM OR TRYING TO
PURCHASE AMMUNITION MAKING SURE
THAT WE CAN ATTEND TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS BEFORE THEY CREATE
DAMAGE IN OUR COMMUNITY
CENTRALLY WE HAVE THIS APPS
PROGRAM WE ALL KNOW ABOUT WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. WHICH
HAS ITS OWN ISSUES WE'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE SURE IS
THAT IF AN INDIVIDUAL TRIES TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM OR AMMUNITION
AND THEY'RE IN THE APPS PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SHALL
NOTIFY THE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED AND
THEY CAN DO FOLLOW UP WORK TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT INDIVIDUAL
DOES NOT POSSESS AMMUNITION OR
FIREARMS I WORKED ON THIS ISSUE
WITH SENATOR NIELSEN FROM ACROSS
ABOUT FOR THE PAST FEW YEARS AND
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE
I DON'T THINK YOU. THANK YOU MR
MCCARTY. SEEING NO MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. CARCLUB
LAUREL. THE SERVER NUMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THEM. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE ANTI VOTE I SIXTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
WE WILL PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS
NINETY THREE. THROUGH NINETY
EIGHT WE DISPENSED WITH FILE
ITEM NINETY NINE. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEMS ONE
HUNDRED. THROUGH. ONE OH THREE.
WE DO HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SEEING HEARING NONE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
TWENTY TO FORTY FIVE. BY SEVERAL
MONTHS. CLICK TO OPEN THE ROLE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SATURDAY.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
WELL CLOSE ROLE CHILD BUT I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION. THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
I WOULD ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS AT THIS TIME. AND
GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL ATTENTION
TO YOUR COLLEAGUES WERE
ADJOURNING. IN THE MEMORY.
MEMBERS WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AT
THIS TIME OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ASKED TODAY THAT
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF VERNAY
VERACRUZ IN. WHO IS AN AMAZING
ENTREPRENEUR AND HUMANITARIAN
FROM CHICO CALIFORNIA. BERNAY
ATTENDED CHRISTIAN BROTHERS HIGH
SCHOOL IN SACRAMENTO. AND HE MET
HIS WIFE ETHEL IN NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BEFORE MOVING UP TO CHICO
. HE WAS A SELF MADE MAN WITH
JUST A HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION HE
ROSE TO BE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
LARGEST ROAD CONSTRUCTION
COMPANY IN SACRAMENTO AND READY. BUT AFTER HAVING THAT SUCCESS
HE WANTED TO GIVE BACK TO THIS
COMMUNITY AND DID SO IN SO MANY
WAYS AFTER HIS RETIREMENT HE
SPENT MUCH OF HIS TIME
VOLUNTEERING. AND HELPING OTHERS
. IS VERY ACTIVE COMMUNITY
MEMBER IN CHICO WHERE HE
VOLUNTEERED FOR ELEVEN YEARS
WITH THE READING PALS PROGRAM
WHICH HELPS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
STUDENTS WHO NEED EXTRA SUPPORT.
IN READING. IS ALSO A LONG TIME
MEMBER OF THE ROTARY CLUB. AND
VOLUNTEERED WITH THE SALVATION
ARMY. HE LIVED BY THE MOTTO OF
SERVICE ABOVE SELF. MANY
CERTAINLY EXEMPLIFIED THAT IN
HIS LIFE. WE ARE DEEPLY SADDENED
TO LEARN OF HIS PASSING. WE'RE
NAY ALWAYS WENT ABOVE AND BEYOND
FOR PEOPLE. MANY PUT IS
COMMUNITY FIRST. HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS LOVING WIFE. HIS BROTHERS
PHIL AND WIFE CAROL. IT IS
CHILDREN RENEE CHRIS DARRELL
CHERYL BETHEL DAVID AND GINA AS
WELL AS MANY GRANDCHILDREN. MANY
PEOPLE ABLE TO CALL HIM THEIR
FRIEND AND MENTOR THEY WERE NAY
WILL BE TRULY MISSED BY ALL WHO
KNEW HIM. MEMBERS ASKED WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY EVERY.
VERA CRUZ IN. THANK YOU MISS
GALLAGHER. AND MR BELLONE ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF- PERSONAL FRIEND
AND A FRIEND OF THE SANTA MONICA
COMMUNITY AND BEYOND TO THE LATE
HE OUT KATAGIRI. MS CATEGORY
BEGAN HER CAREER AS A RESEARCHER
AT THE RAND CORPORATION BACK IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND
CONTINUED WORKING THERE UNTIL
TWENTY SIXTEEN AS THE DIRECTOR
OF COMMUNITY RELATIONS. WALLET
RANDY HOW WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
NUMEROUS RAN PROJECTS BUT ONE OF
THE ORGANIZATION'S SUCH A
PROJECT OF WHICH SHE WAS MOST
PROUD WAS HELPING TO RAISE
MILLIONS TO LAUNCH THE INSTITUTE
FOR CIVIL JUSTICE. WHICH FOCUSED
ON A BETTER WAY TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. KATAGIRI BECAME
INVOLVED IN MANY LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS TO HER ROLE AS
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY RELATIONS
BUT IT SOON BECAME CLEAR THAT
THIS COMMITMENT WAS DRIVEN BY A
FIERCE PASSION AND NOT JUST A
JOB RESPONSIBILITY AS YOU
STACKED UP TITLE UPON TITLE IN
VIRTUALLY EVERY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION. IN SANTA MONICA IT
SEEMS. MICHAEL RICH THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF ROUND NOTED
THAT EAEU HAD A STRONG MORAL
COMPASS WAS TIRELESS IN TERMS OF
ENERGY LEVEL AND WAS REALLY AT
HER BEST WHEN SHE WAS HELPING
OTHER PEOPLE PARTICULARLY PEOPLE
WHO CAME FROM DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS. OR HAD OTHER
OBSTACLES THAT THEY WERE CAPABLE
OF OVERCOMING IF ONLY THEY HAD
HELP. SHE PRIDED HERSELF ON
ENABLING PEOPLE LIKE THAT TO
SUCCEED. ACCORDING TO OTHERS WHO
KNEW HER KATAGIRI SEEM TO ONLY
BECOME BUSIER IN RETIREMENT
DOUBLING DOWN ON OUR COMMITMENTS
TO THE MANY NONPROFIT BOARDS
THAT YOU SERVED ON. AT THE TIME
OF HER DEATH CATEGORY WAS CHAIR
OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF
PROVIDENCE SAINT JOHN'S HEALTH
CENTER VICE CHAIR OF THE SANTA
MONICA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. AND
CULTURE OF THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
DISTRICT ADVISORY COMMITTEE OF
THE SANTA MONICA MALIBU UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. EVEN IN
SICKNESS KATAGIRI CONTINUE TO
WORK ON A TUITION ASSISTANCE
BOND THAT WAS NAMED IN HER HONOR
THE E. L. KATAGIRI FUND WAS
TITLED BY HERS BUT BY KATAGIRI
HERSELF WITH THE I. A. O. THAT
SPELLED OUT HER FIRST NAME.
STANDING FOR INTEGRITY AND
OPTIMISM NOT REALLY SPEAKS. JUST
AHEAD IT REALLY TELLS YOU THE
STORY ABOUT THE OUT THAT'S WHO
SHE WAS. THE FUND IS A PROJECT
OF THE SANTA MONICA COLLEGE
FOUNDATION AND IS RAISING MONEY
TO PROVIDE TUITION ASSISTANCE
FOR SMC'S EARLY EDUCATION LAB
SCHOOL. AGAIN A PASSION OF HERS.
MS KATAGIRI PASSED ON APRIL
TWENTY EIGHTH AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTY WHILE BATTLING CANCER
AND IS SURVIVED BY HER SISTER.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY. OF MY
FRIEND AND MENTOR YEAH KATAGIRI. THANK IMMEASURABLE THANK YOU
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS RICHARD IN
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
MAY TENTH CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY MAY ELEVENTH CHECKING
SESSION THURSDAY MAY TWELFTH
FLOOR SESSION IS AT. NINE AM ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAIN A MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING HEARING OR FOR
THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER BLUE MOOSE MISTER
GALLAGHER SECOND SET THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED. UNTIL THURSDAY
MAY THE TWELFTH AT NINE AM WE
ARE RICHARD.